resuelve para allí y tenemos tres yemas
siete menor que dos y también se debe
cumplir que cuatro yemas 8 sea mayor que
menos 48 entonces nuestra variable jet
debe satisfacer esta desigualdad y
también la del lado derecho debe
satisfacer ambas y para poder resolver
eso como hemos estado haciendo los
separamos en dos problemas aparte y
vemos cuál es el conjunto de valores que
cumplen ambos muy bien entonces vamos a
tomarnos 3 y 7 menor que 2 y para ir
despejando la aie lo que podemos es
restar 2 de ambos lados para que el lado
derecho para que todas las 10 queden de
lado izquierdo esencialmente entonces
del lado izquierdo tenemos tres menos 2
es de 7 y esto debe ser menor que 2 - 2
ya que es cero así que tenemos
finalmente yemas 7 es menor que cero ya
finalmente para despejarla y podemos
simplemente restar 7
ambos lados restamos 7 de ambos lados ok
y entonces me queda 77 se cancelan ese
es el punto de restar 7 y me queda del
lado izquierdo y menor que es 0 menos 7
que es menos 7 muy bien aquí tenemos
nuestra primera restricción que que nos
impone el problema y ahora vamos a ver
qué ocurre con la segunda es decir qué
ocurre con esta desigualdad muy bien
entonces tenemos 4 y más 8 es mayor que
menos 48 entonces lo primero que a mí se
me ocurre es restar 8 de ambos lados
restamos 8 de ambos lados
estamos 8 y lo que me queda es que esto
se cancela por supuesto y tenemos 4 y es
mayor que menos 48 menos 8 son son de
signos iguales entonces en realidad
sumamos los números y le dejamos el
signo y es 48 más 8 son 56 muy bien
entonces lo siguiente es dividir todo
entre 4 dividir a ambos lados entre 4
que no me afecta la desigualdad porque 4
es positivo y sólo se cambia cuando
dividimos o multiplicamos por algo
negativo así que en este caso no pasa
nada estos cuatro se cancelan y me queda
que ya es mayor que menos 56 entre 4
entonces va a menos 56 entre 4 bueno 4
por 10 son 44 por 4 son 16 así que son
14 verdad
es menos de 56 entre 4 es 14 4 por 4 16
y llevamos 14 y 14 por 14 y 1 son 5 muy
bien entonces ya es mayor que menos 14
pero no hay que perder de vista que se
debe cumplir ambos
mejor lo ponemos con mayúscula así se
debe cumplir que ya es menor que menos 7
y al mismo tiempo que ya debe ser mayor
que menos 14 muy bien entonces como se
grafica haría esto esto si lo ponemos en
la recta numérica
nuestra recta numérica quizás por
ejemplo aquí está el menos 7
- 8 9 10 11 12 13 y 14 aquí está el
menos 14 no sé quizás a cada menos 6
menos 5 - 4 - 3 - 2 menos 10 siendo el 0
pero bueno ya no nos interesan los demás
entonces el amarillo la solución
amarilla me dice que debe ser menor que
menos 7 entonces el menos 7 no lo
incluimos y nos vamos hacia la izquierda
y nos podemos seguir tanto como queramos
hacia la izquierda verdad sin embargo
tenemos otra restricción la restricción
morada que me dice que de que debe ser
más grande que menos 14 no puede ser 14
entonces nos vamos hacia la derecha y no
seguiríamos hasta la derecha excepto que
no podemos pasar de menos 7 verdad no
podemos pasar de menos 7 y finalmente
nuestro conjunto solución es justamente
este este conjunto en que va de menos 14
a menos 7 muy bien ese es nuestro
conjunto solución así que ya nada más
para terminar y estar bastante cómodos
con nuestra respuesta vamos a intentar
algunos
ej
qué tal si nos tomamos algo por aquí
menos 8 19
por ejemplo este que es el menos 10 ok
si sustituimos menos 10 como se
encuentra en el conjunto solución debe
cumplir ambas ambas desigualdades
vamos a ver 3 por menos 10 7 debe ser
menor que 2 x menos 10 y 3 por menos 10
son menos 30 más 7 es menor que menos 20
y menos 30 más 7 son menos 23 que
claramente es menos 20 verdad este es
mucho más negativo que menos 20 a ver
vamos a intentar alguno que no que no
funcione a pérez pero antes tenemos que
ver que cumple también la otra 4 x menos
10 más 8 será cierto que es mayor que
menos 48 4 por menos 10 más 8 es debe
ser mayor que menos 48 ok 4 x menos 10
es menos 40 más 8 debe ser mayor que
menos 48
y menos 40 más 8 son menos 32 que si es
cierto que es más grande que menos 48 es
menos negativo verdad y si nos damos
cuenta por ejemplo el 0 el 0 si lo
sustituimos aquí tenemos 3 por 0 más 7
pues son 7 que debe ser menor que 2 por
0 que es 0 y no es cierto que 7 sea
menor que cero entonces 0 la que no
cumple es esta desigualdad si por
ejemplo nos tomáramos aquí menos 15 la
que no va a cumplir es la desigualdad de
la derecha ok entonces espero que esto
haya sido bastante útil